wann kann denn wirklich endgültig mal
dem dauerhaften Morden ein P vorgesetzt
werden muss man dann nicht auch ganz
ehrlich und offen über zwei Staaten
reden muss man sich auch nicht mal
Gedanken machen über die
Siedlungspolitik aber ich bin der
Meinung das richtige Problem liegt doch
ganz woanders und das kann man nicht mit
Gewalt lösen denn Gewalt kann keine
Lösung sein hier müssen sich die
mit Hilfe der großen Nation an einen
Tisch setzen müssen no wirklich mal an
das Übel der Wurzel herangehen und da
müssen sich die Politiker wirklich was
einfangen lassen dass man vielleicht
auch den Arabern kleines bisschen
gerecht wird die haben doch auch eine
eine Berechtigung auf ihre Existenz das
ist doch ganz klar sonst kriegen wir das
Norden doch nie mehr
[Musik]
raus